logement inaccessibles suite à un
incendie ou une explosion incapacité de
travail après un attentat touché
physiquement et ou matériellement il est
souvent difficile pour les victimes de
composer avec les complexités
administratives pour y voir plus clair
et bien j'accueille tout de suite jean
luc chaumar avocat jours donc nous
sommes deux mois après l'explosion d'un
immeuble dans le quartier de la gare à
dijon pratiquement un an après les
attentats du bataclan victime d'une de
ces catastrophes les démarches ne sont
pas les mêmes mais d'abord on commence
par penser à soi on commence par soi
vous savez quand on subit un événement
comme celui-ci le traumatisme personnel
il est aussi important qu'il est varié
donc humainement déjà ce premier message
c'est à donner c'est commencer à penser
à vous autant que possible essayer
d'être au mieux de ce que vous pouvez et
puis on verra ensuite pour les démarches
administratives et pour aider à se
sentir mieux et après pouvoir avoir
enfin en tout cas entamer certaines
démarches
il ya bien sûr des associations qui se
spécialisent de plus en plus oui si vous
voulez l'idée générale c'est que quand
on est dans des phénomènes de groupe
comme cela où les victimes sont très
nombreuses les victimes sont un petit
peu perdues et par pitié ne sais pas
vraiment comment les regrouper et l'idée
c'est de souvent créer une association
des victimes d'un événement précis et
grâce à cela on regroupe tout le monde
et puis on a un interlocuteur les
services administratifs et judiciaires
ou un interlocuteur c'est l'association
et puis chacune des victimes a un
interlocuteur c'est de cette association
une fois qu'on a pensé à soit par quoi
peut-on commencer
en droit d attendre on commence par
s'assurer que on est bien répertorié
comme victime et puis ensuite on va voir
une association de victimes
d'infractions il existe des associations
qui sont là pour vous aider
même s'il ne s'agit pas d'un événement
aussi exceptionnel que celui que nous
connaissons je parle de l'adavip parce
que tout le monde la connaît et je parle
aussi de la permanence victimes de
l'ordre des avocats
il y à des avocats qui sont là pour vous
aider pour vous donner les premières
clés et pour vous accompagner
lorsqu'on est victime comme cela il est
toujours important aussi de se
rapprocher d'autres personnes qui ont
connu les mêmes catastrophes
alors ça c'est un phénomène qui est un
phénomène classique on a besoin
d'entendre les autres parce que comme
nous ne sommes les seuls à avoir vécu ça
en est les seuls à le comprendre
donc il faut qu'on en discute entre nous
les autres ne savent pas les autres
n'ont pas vécu alors c'est très
important aussi dans le cadre de ces
associations de permettre cet échange ce
dialogue de deux d'échanger les
expériences qui sont toutes différentes
avec tout des façons d'avoir vécu tout
cela qui sont différentes
c'est en effet un des ddd quelque chose
qui est très important pardon et en cas
de procès vous conseillez donc de se
constituer partie civile
alors ça c'est c'est aussi un autre
élément qui est important une victime
est là
besoin d'être reconnus comme tels ça
c'est très classique donc on a besoin en
effet d'aller au procès et on a besoin
d'être entendue par la justice parce que
la justice elle est là pour nous
entendre pour ne dire vous êtes victime
nous avons un message de compassion cet
essentiel la victime et n'a pas besoin
du procès pour être indemnisé des
préjudices qu'elle a subit généralement
l'indemnisation se passe avant procès
si vous voulez on va prendre on va
prendre les événements du bataclan
puisque malheureusement on va entre
guillemets parler de cette date
anniversaire c'est quoi l'objectif
l'objectif pour l'état c'est de
permettre à ce qu'on appelle le fonds de
garantie d'indemnisation des victimes de
permettre à ces victimes d'être
indemnisé le plus rapidement possible
donc on va essayer de faire que toutes
ces victimes soient justement
correctement indemnisée avant qu'il
existe un un procès un jour parce qu'un
problème de délai après bas parce que
problèmes de délais parce que vous savez
qu'il y à un auteur présumé en prison
vous avez compris qu'il ne disait rien
vous avez compris qu'on attendrait rien
de lui
et donc cette dimension là pour les
victimes
elle est à prendre en considération une
victime elle a besoin d'être de que son
préjudice soit réparé et puis dans le
cadre de l'instruction qui est en cours
cette victime elle a besoin aussi parce
qu'elle est partie civile c'est à dire
parce qu'elle vient ce participer au au
procès et à l'instruction et bien elle
va avoir des informations
et elle va au jour le jour pouvoir
suivre ce qui se passe sur le plan
judiciaire
merci pour toutes ces informations jean
ux marc et puis